foreign
[Music]
ladies what's the poorest a guy did
around you
I saw that I didn't read the thread but
I've seen I've I've seen that go offered
to buy me a drink and poured half of it
in an empty cup for himself and gave me
the other half I would never let this go
half the drink bro where did he even get
an empty glass
where's he even getting him to you he
must have asked for that can I have her
that fam can I have a JD on the rocks
and an empty An Empty Glass
wow that's disgusting oh that's more
than that's foul bro yeah yeah
some guy wrote after seeing what these
guys in the quote tweets are getting
away with I need to up my audacity
[Laughter]
I need to up my audacity the certain
things I read about like what mandem do
and I think so why am I trying so hard
facts what am I trying out so hard to be
an upstanding citizen why am I the
gentleman yeah bro why am I the chat we
got man like ringing up like a man
bringing up the sightings and like just
a Madness bro don't ever speak about me
again
am I just loving loving everyone
cherishing everyone looking after them
yeah bare manners yeah oh and these men
are doing the least and getting away
with it getting away with all of it
murder
ask me out for drinks and he showed up
to the spot with warm vodka in a crushed
water bottle and then told me to buy
myself a cup of Sprite from the bar
cracked water bowl
happens back from his back pocket yeah
and he just crinkled yeah yeah
vodka Sprite on Ice get some Sprite from
the bar you buy some Sprite from the bar
I got the Vodka ready oh God
I wasn't even getting away with this
where are these men I don't know bro
that's crazy I wouldn't even have the
audacity or the balls to do that
it's weak that plastic's weak bro
oh that's so embarrassing it sense to me
I couldn't watch her face react to that
I can't babe just go go buy a Sprite for
the bus confused what did you mean what
do you mean just vodka here are you just
smell that that's that Au yeah oh wow
wow wow wow wow I can't believe stuff
I've got us
Pat I'll tell you what just buy one
Sprite but ask for an empty glass on the
side yeah yeah because you don't need
all that Sprite facts facts
about our teeth in it facts well I got a
cheap way I've got a cheap date for us
don't worry babes
we took his kids to the arcade and he
told them to use their imagination on
the games
just taken
Ambiance take it all in taking the sound
and taking the smell taking the sights
nah bro since then once when you're
shooting but it's
it's not new you gotta put no money in
it
it's a demo
wow wow wow wow wow wow you're faking
the whole thing is your imagination oh
Services bro I'm calling Social Services
facts this one we went to Chipotle and
instead of him getting guac on his
burrito we drove he drove us to Walmart
to get an avocado
thank you
[__] he drove us to Walmart to buy an
avocado to be fair I don't want to be
that guy I I didn't have Chipotle for
the first time like two weeks ago the
quack's like 250 boss
the quarks are amazingly expensive it
doesn't it doesn't make sense bro does
it back no it's mid Quark 250
quack is usually teeth though in in
burritos yeah when you add guac and add
this in
itself
the one I packed was 250 I couldn't
believe it oh wow obviously I'm not
gonna go drive and buy a [__] avocado
and then do what yeah in his shell just
mush it and just spread man over there
mustard wow no seasoning no lime juice
nothing just avocado ah no chopped
tomatoes known that's disgusting yeah
guys are in broke shit's wild It's the
funniest thing is this the finest thing
because they don't give a [__]
are you with me or not
oh
whether you love me
love me so why are you saying what are
you saying that's what I've got to offer
are you down I'm not paying 250 for
guacamole what do you think this is bags
that can go on something else started
selling water while we were on a date I
said where the [__] do you get the water
from he started pulling water out of his
pockets I'm mortified just thinking
about it
no one can show me water bro that's
insane started putting water out of his
pockets
that's hustle culture yeah wow I
remember
um speak enough to be fair if you go to
like Florida or something potentially
like La you can sell waterpro
okay I went to when I was in uh Orlando
yeah in Orlando yeah the homeless guys
bro if you walk we were thirsty so we
went and got a crate of water for the
Villa bro listen yeah walking down
through this park yeah to get back from
the from the shop to the [__] car
yeah we had to go through this park yeah
but roll these homeless [__] yeah yo
let me have some water yeah and then I
had like a pack of 20s
again
share it
Sherry if you're so [__] thirsty
share it facts facts by the time I was
scared bro because I was thinking I
don't know what I don't want to get in
between a man and his hydration
[Music]
because when I'm thirsty
and it was baking that day when I'm
thirsty bro I lose it
and I've got a yard I don't know what
he's manner on bro yo let me get some
water
oh the fear
remember I remember he was black and
dirty oh that's all I remember
six two black and dirty bro I said run
me some water
you know
six two black and dirty
wow
wow that what a profile
4K what's her profile you can see the
whole thing of 4K bro I dashed in the
water
you feared for your life I'm not getting
in the way of a man in his thirst
there's just no way that's hilarious
okay let me run it back and I've got a
few more
um so ladies what's the poorest [__] a
guy's done around you
he had Chipotle napkins in a bathroom
instead of toilet paper that's crazy
stuff that's probably rough as well I
don't even know how Chipotle napkins are
but I'm pretty sure it's just a thin
little it's like that bro it's just like
a thizzy little stuff yeah it's not the
one but
I remember a few months ago
I screamed the house down because I
I ran out of toilet roll yeah
and forgot to get my I run out of toilet
roll had to shower my [__] yes
I just shower my [__] bro I was
living because I was dressed
it's hard to get ass naked shower again
dry cream deodorant again because I'm
not I'm not gonna not wash my armpits
the whole thing yeah the whole routine
again yeah this is my beard again
the next day I I forgot to get toilet
roll again I sat down looked at my
little dispenser scream
scream oh peek there's no I've never
wanted to just pull my jaws up and deal
with the cake buddy I've never it's the
worst thing I've never wanted to but in
my head I thought I'm gonna get worms or
something yeah I'm gonna get worms
outside with a cake oh let me get back
in the shower speaking of the tissue in
America in that yard the softest thing
on my back it's voluptuous bro the
softest thing to ever scrape my body I
remember and I needed it because my guts
were doing beats that first night
yeah but the first time we got um James
and I we got a milkshake as well with
all my days it was a banging Milkshake
the milkshake was so buff and my lactose
intolerance said say less they swear
yeah there's sugar tax over there oh my
god did it run through me
wow I'm telling you after that milkshake
I woke up every morning in pain
4 30 a.m I woke up three times I woke up
three times the first night right in my
lower intestine I was rolling through
that I said I can't take it bro
ran to the toilet every morning
I remember saying to you man the day
after like fam accountability yeah I'm
not touching Dairy this whole trip and
you were like fun
those cookies and cream goodness bro ran
through me I [__] lava and I said bro
it wasn't okay it wasn't okay it was
random bro because I had the shits the
whole trip and as soon as I got back to
England my stomach I feel fine yeah bro
same
he was crazy we were eating garbage we
were eating absolute trash it was just
garbage absolutely broccoli last night
I'm saying ten to Sam and salmon
broccoli and baby potatoes
dude I had chicken broccoli and baby
potatoes bro oh I was so good garlic yes
I'm
[__] oregano
I need a nourishment yeah I needed
[__] minerals wow [__] America bro
you man learn how to eat food
Jesus Christ Jesus all right a couple
more from the Fred uh what's the poorest
uh guys things like what's the poorest
thing you guys ever done in front of you
yeah cool
uh this chick said pocketed the ones his
homeboy threw out the strip
pockets are the ones
I can't I can't see that yeah I can't
see stuff like that I couldn't see that
if if we're at strip club and that
happened and I see one of you man just
just I'm putting my foot yeah oh my foot
and say that's the bad yeah I'm banging
you out she popped her [__] for that
what did you do it's for them yeah stop
if you wonder once Ben Sutton do some
grips the wall and shakes at him if he
wasn't [__] him once
it's hilarious
[Music]
foreign